[موسيقى]
انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه نص صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
حزمه عقوباتنا امريكيه الجديده موجهه ضد
ايران وتطالب شركات صينيه تساعد طهران في
صنع المسيرات
استراليا تقرر شراء غواصات امريكيه نوويه
والصين تحضرها وتدعو للتخلي عن عقليه
الحرب البارده
واشنطن تنفي تدريب طيارنا اوكرانيين على
طائرات اف 16 وتدرس تركيب اسلحه امريكيه
على المقاتلات الاوكرانيه
خطوات مغربيه وسودانيه نحو تسلم عدد من
عائلات مقاتلي داعش المحتجزين في سجون
العراق وسوريا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في اخبار الساعه
اذا نبداها من اسرائيل حصيله عمليه اطلاق
النار التي وقعت في تل ابيب قبل قليل
ترتفع الان الى خمسه مصابين اذا في اخر
تحديث في خبر عاجل ورد للتو اذا
بالتزامن مع هذه التطورات اذا وصف رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو الهجوم الذي
وقع في تل ابيب بن الخطير وذلك بعد ان
اصيب خمسه اشخاص اذا كما ذكرت باطلاق
النار وسطات تل ابيب احدهم في حاله حرجه
حيث فتح شخص النار على مجموعه من الاشخاص
عند مقهى في شارع ديزني احد اهم الشوارع
الحيويه في تل ابيب الشرطه الاسرائيليه
قالت انها حيدت احد المنفذين وتلاحق اخر
نعرف اكثر من مراسلنا في القدس زياد حلبي
زياد اهلا بك الحصيله ترتفع الى خمسه
مصابين اذا ما الذي نعرفه حتى الان عن
عمليه اطلاق النار في تل ابيب
التقديرات في الشرطه الاسرائيليه بان ثمه
منفذا واحدا لهذه العمليه الشرطه
الاسرائيليه قتلته عمليا اطلقت عليه النار
من قبل رجلي شرطه في عين في منطقه قريبه
من تنفيذ يعني على بعد 200 متر من مكان
تنفيذ العمليه بالقرب من المقهى
وجره طبعا وما زال هناك حال تاهب امني جرى
البحث للاعتقاد في البدايه بان هناك اكثر
من منفذ في المنطقه لكن حاليا التقديرات
لدى الشرطه الاسرائيليه على الاقل حتى
اللحظه بان هناك منفذا واحدا هناك ثلاثه
اسرائيليين فعليا اصيبوا في هذه
العمليه واحد منهم اصابته حرجه جدا والاخر
متوسطه والثالث طفيفه نعم طيب اخي الحصيله
وصلتنا هي خمسه ربما بانتظار اذن المزيد
من التفاصيل طيب دعني اسالك زياد اطلاق
النار عمليه اطلاق النار هل استهدفت
تجمعا لمتظاهرين الذين يعني يتظاهرون ضد
الاصلاحات القضائيه التي يريدها نتنياهو
ام لا نتحدث عن مكان عادي
لا هي بعيده للمظاهرات حقيقه جرت اطلاق
النار على ثلاثه كانوا في بالقرب من مقهى
في شارع ديزنوف وهو شارع معروف اساسا
بالمقاهي وبالحياه الليليه في تل ابيب
ولهذا قد يكون اختاره المنفذ اساسا
حدث معه خلل في المسدس عندما بدا باطلاق
النار
وعندها يعني قتلته الشرطه الاسرائيليه
وحاول اطلاق النار اكثر ولكن المسدس تعرض
الى عطل معين ما ادى الى وقف العمليه
العمليه لكن كان هناك توقعات بان عمليات
فرديه كهذه قد تحدث على جانبي الخط الاخضر
ردا على الهجمات الاسرائيليه اليوميه على
الفلسطينيين اخرها كان في بلده جبع جنوب
جنين اليوم صحيح عند هذا هل تم تاكيد هويه
منفذ عمليه تل ابيب زياد
لدينا معلومات عن الهويه لكن طبعا في
انتظار التاكد رسميا هو نستطيع ان نقول
بانه من الضفه الغربيه هذا حاليا ما يمكن
ان نقوله عن المنفذ عمره 23 عاما
وعمليا كان نفذ العمليه كما قلت بواسطه
مسدس اطلق النار على الاسرائيليين هناك
على فكره هي ليست بعيده عن العمليه
الاخيره التي جرت في تل ابيب يعني اعتقد
300 متر شيء من هذا القبيل عن المقهى
السابق الذي حدثت فيه عمليه نوعيه اكثر من
هذه بكثير في اكثر من مكان عمليه حدثت
هناك في نفس الشارع شارع ديزنجو في هذه
العمليه السادسه في الصلاتين الاخيرتين في
منطقه تل ابيب نعم طيب
على صعيد الحكومه الاسرائيليه كان هناك
تصريح لنتنياهو حول هذه العمليه ماذا
نتوقع كذلك من اجراءات اسرائيليه بعد هذه
العمليه الجديده في تل ابيب
ليس هناك لاسرائيل ما تفعله في مواجهه هذه
العمليات هذا شاب قرر ان يدفع يقوم بعملها
واطلق النار وانتهى الموضوع وبالتالي ليس
هناك قيمه حقيقه للاجراءات الامنيه في
مواجهه العمليات الفرديه هذا سبق وشرحناه
هي المشكله الاساسيه لدى الاسرائيليين مثل
هذه العمليات عاده صهيب لا معلومات
استخباراتيه حولها عندما يتخذ شخص واحد
قرار بدون شركاء ان يقوم بعمل من هذا
النوع عمليا لا يمكن تقريبا معرفه ذلك الا
وقت العمليه وبالتالي الاجراءات المتخذه
عاده هي زياده عدد الشرطه ولكن المشكله في
اسرائيل كما رايت اليوم بان جل عمل الشرطه
هو في المظاهرات ومحاوله فتح الشوارع
ثلاثه الاف شرطي كانوا في منطقه تل ابيب
ربما هذا يفسر ايضا سرعه تدخل الشرطه في
المكان لانها كانت ببساطه متواجده بكثافه
في تلك المنطقه
نعم هناك اعلام اسرائيلي نشر على ما يبدو
صوره اوليه للمنفذ بعد ان قامت الشرطه
الاسرائيليه امام
باطلاق النار عليه اذن سنتابع معك اذا
المزيد من التطورات على توافرها معك زياد
حلبي اذا حتى الان شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
فرضت الخزانه الامريكيه عقوبات على ايران
هي الثانيه خلال يومين وشمله العقوبات
الجديده 39 فردا وكيانا بما فيها عقوبات
ضد كيانات مقرها الصين وشركه تعمل على
تصنيع المسيرات وعقوبات على شبكات
المصرفيه تساهم بدخول مليارات الدولارات
الى ايران سنويا بحسب ما اوردت الوزاره
هكذا وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه التزام
واشنطن بفرض عقوبات على النظام الايراني
وتعطيل شبكات تمويله وذلك بعد افرضت
الخزانه الامريكيه عقوبات على ما وصفته
بشبكه الظل المصرفيه المكونه من 39 كيانا
والتي تسهل انشطه ايران للتهرب من
العقوبات
معنى من واشنطن دكتور حسن هاشميان الباحث
في الشان الايراني دكتور اهلا بك في اخبار
الساعه كيف ستؤثر يا ترى هذه العقوبات
الامريكيه الجديده على شبكه الظل الماليه
التي كانت تتهرب من خلالها ايران من
العقوبات
نعم تحياتي لكم والى مشاهدين العربيه هذه
العقوبات خلافا للعقوبات السابقه ستؤثر
بشكل كبير على الموارد الماليه التي تاتي
الى نظام الولي الفقير الشبكات الماليه
والبنوك السريه والشركات التابعه على في
الصين في هونغ كون في الامارات في تركيا
وحتى في باكستان كانت تعمل كعروب ماليه
لجسد الولي الفقيه يعني كل هذه المده التي
كان النظام يعاني من العقوبات خاصه
العقوبات الماليه هذه الشبكات السريه كانت
تلصق النظام بالاسواق الماليه العالميه
وتوفر اموال كبيره لهذا النظام خاصه للحرس
في الداخل
والميليشيات في الخارج ولذلك انا اعتقد
هذه الخطوه خطوه جدا مهمه ولكن مشكلتها ان
هذه الخطوه لم تشمل كل الشبكات الماليه
والشركات
والبنوك السريه المتعلقه بالنظام الايراني
نعم طيب ماذا نعرف كذلك عن شبكه الظل هذه
الماليه
والطرق التي كانت تنتهجها من اجل ان يتم
الالتفاف على العقوبات المفروضه على
النظام الايراني في اي القطاعات بالتحديد
دكتور
انا اعتقد النظام الايراني وسع هذه
الشركات في كل القطاعات ولكن خاصه في
القطاع
البتروكيميائيات البترو كان بيترك
ميمياويات لم تضع بشكل كامل او لم تخضع
بشكل كامل للعقوبات الامريكيه وايضا
العقوبات الدوليه ولذلك كانت واجهه
للشركات المتعلقه بهذا القطاع لصناعه هناك
مؤسسات ماليه تتبع على هذه الشركات وتم
العمل في موضوع انتقال الموارد الماليه
الى داخلنا ولذلك انا اعتقد ان النظام
الايراني منذ حكومه احمد نجاه والحكومات
التاليه اسس هذا الشركات وهناك اشخاص جدا
قويين ومسؤولين رفيع المستوى كانوا يعملون
في هذا الاتجاه دكتور حسن هاشميان مباشره
من واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لك على انضمامك
الينا الليله
واثناء لقاء جمع وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
بنظيره الامريكي في تل ابيب شدد جالنت على
ضروره استعداد بلاده واشنطن لاي عمل محتمل
ضد ايران كما اكد وزير الدفاع الاسرائيليه
انه لا يتم السماح لايران بالحصول على
سلاح النووي من جهته شدد اوستن على تركيز
المحادثات على التهديدات الايرانيه واكد
اوستن التزام واشنطن بامن اسرائيل بشكل
قوي وان المساعدات العسكريه لاسرائيل
ستبقى عند مستوياتها
الولايات المتحده ملتزمه بامر اسرائيل
وسنستمر في ذلك الرئيس بايدن اكد خلال
زيارته لاسرائيل على قوه الروابط بين
شعبينا واسرائيل شريك مهم للولايات
المتحده نعمل مع اسرائيل وندعمها في ضمان
امنها كما نشعر بقلق بالغ من زياده ايران
لتخصيب اليورانيوم وتهديد امن المنطقه من
خلال دعمها للارهاب ونعمل على منعها من
امتلاك سلاح النووي كذلك الولايات المتحده
قلقه ايضا من عنف المستوطنين ضد
الفلسطينيين بشكل خاص
قبل ذلك شدد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلياهو
على ضروره تبني نهج حازم ضد ايران وقال ان
من يعتقد ان ايران ستترك للحصول على سلاح
النووي مخطئ واشار الى اجنده مشتركه بين
اسرائيل وامريكا لمنع ايران من امتلاك
سلاح النووي
لدينا اجنده مشتركه لمنع ايران من امتلاك
السلاح النووي والتصدي لاي عدوان قد تشنه
طهران للحفاظ على امن وازدهار المنطقه
والسعي لتوسيع دائره السلام
[موسيقى]
قال مسؤول اوروبي مطلع ان استراليا تعتزم
شراء ما لا يقل عن اربع غواصات تعمل بطاقه
نوويه من طراز فرجينيا في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه حيث اشار الى ان هذه
الصفقه هي جزء من شراكه دفاعيه الناشئه
انظر اليها على نطاق واسع لانها محاوله
لمواجهه طموحات العسكريه الصينيه في
المحيط الهادئ اضاف انه من المرجح ان تزيد
الغواصات الامريكيه من زياراتها للموانين
الاستراليه في السنوات المقبله قبل
التسليم النهائي للغواصات الاستراليه
الجديده
في المقابل وصفت المتحدثه باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه ماونينج استحواذ
استراليا على غواصه نوويه من الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا وصفته بالانتشار النووي
الخطير داعيه الدول الثلاث الى التخلي عن
عقليه الحرب البارده على حد وصفها
فيما يتعلق بالتعاون بين الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا واستراليا بشان الغواصه النوويه
فالصين اعلنت مرارا موقفها الرسمي نعتقد
ان التعاون بين دول الثلاث يشكل انتشارا
نوويا خطيرا ويؤثر على النظام الدولي في
سياسه عدم انتشار النووي ويحفز سباق
التسلح ويقوض السلامه والاستقرار في منطقه
اسيا والمحيط الهادئ كما ان هذا الامر
يقابل بمعارضه على نطاق واسع من قبل دول
المنطقه والمجتمع الدوليه نحث الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا واستراليا على التخلي
عن عقليه الحرب البارده والوفاء باخلاص
بالتزاماتها الدوليه وبذل المزيد للاسهام
في السلامه والاستقرار الدوليين
المناوشات بين الولايات المتحده والصين
باتت تؤخذ على محمل الجد وتحذيرات خرجت من
بكين الى العلن بطابع عسكري حيث دعا
الرئيس الصيني الى الارتقاء بسرعه اكبر
بالقوات المسلحه الصينيه الى مستوى عالمي
خطابه جاء بعد ايام من تحذيره مندده بحمله
بقياده الولايات المتحده لاحتواء وتطويق
وقمع الصين في المقابل اجرى ايضا سلسله من
الدعوات لتسريع بناء الاعتماد على الذات
في العلوم والتكنولوجيا وتعزيز القدرات
الاستراتيجيه في مجالات الطوارئ الى جانب
جعل سلاسل الصناعه والتوليد اكثر مرونه
وجعل الاحتياطات الوطنيه اكثر قدره على
حمايه الامن القومي
[موسيقى]
وصل وزير الدفاع الامريكي اوستن اذن الى
اسرائيل لكن الاحتجاجات الواسعه عرقله
زيارته حيث نزل عشرات الالاف من
الاسرائيليين الى الشوارع للاحتجاج على
خطط اصلاح النظام القضائي في وقت افاد
مراسل العربيه ان انتشارا كبيرا للشرطه
الاسرائيليه شهده محيط مطار تل ابيب بسبب
احتجاجات على خطط حكوميه تهدف الاصلاح
النظام القضائي مضيفا انا وزير الدفاع
الامريكي الذي وصل الى مطار بن غوريون لن
يدخل اسرائيل
واجرى بالاحرى لقاءاته في المطار وقال ان
واشنطن ستواصل العمل عن كثب مع اسرائيل
لتعزيز الاستقرار الاقليمي ومواجهه
التهديدات المشتركه من خلال التعاون
الدفاعي القوي
وفي السياق اكدت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
الفانتاغون ان وزير الدفاع الامريكي شدد
لرئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي على العواقب
المميته لتوسيع ايران تعاونها العسكري مع
روسيا مشددا على اهميه عدم السماح لايران
بامتلاك سلاح نووي
وبعد قليل في اخبار الساعه جورجيا تستذكر
ايام ثورتها الملونه وحربها مع روسيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اكدت واشنطن ان وجود
طيارين اوكرانيين في قاعده جويه امريكيه
في ولايه اريزونا هدفه ليس تدريبهم على
قياده طائره 16 وانما تقييم امكانيه نصب
صواريخ امريكيه على مقاتلات ميكي وقال
منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي بالبيت الابيض جونربي في
حديث النسيان ان الهدف ليس التدريب وانما
تقييم لامكانيه استخدام انواع معينه من
الاسلحه الامريكيه على مقاتلاتهم اي على
طائرات نيك
اكدت وكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه التابعه
للامم المتحده ان امدادات الكهرباء انقطعت
عن محطه لاول مره منذ نوفمبر 2022 حيث
اشارت الى ان المحطه باتت تعتمد على
مولدات تعمل بالديزل فقط وهو خط دفاع
الاخير لمنع الانصهار الناتج عن ارتفاع
درجه حراره وقود المفعل
اذا سمحنا لهذا بالاستمرار مره تلو الاخرى
فسوف ينفذ حظنا يوما ما اعطي الكلمه لكل
من في هذه القاعه اليوم وفي كل مكان يجب
ان نلتزم بحمايه وسلامه وامن المصنع ونحن
بحاجه الى الالتزام الان ما نحتاجه هو
العمل ونحن نعرف ما يعني هذا ساستمر
وساواصل مشاوراتي واتصالات العاجله لحمايه
محطه زابوريجيا للطاقه النوويه
ومع اشتداد المعارك على الارض والخسائر
البشريه التي يتكبدها الطرفان في الحرب
باتت التعبئه العسكريه ازمه ظهرت في روسيا
ثم يبدو انها انتقلت الى اوكرانيا الان لا
سيما مع عدم وجود امال بانهاء الصراع في
المستقبل المنظور
مجله الايكونست مع اشتداد المعارك في شرقي
اوكرانيا كثفت كييف انشطه التعبئه
العسكريه في الشهرين الاولين من 2023
الجيش الاوكراني يحتاج الى مزيد من القوات
لمواكبه المعارك وتدفق الاسلحه التي
يقدمها الغرب
نيوزويك خدمه الامن الاوكرانيه حجبت 26
قناه على تيليجرام يعتقد انها تساعد من هم
في سن التجنيد على تجنب التعبئه
نيوزويك ماركات جامعه جورج مصر
استراتيجيه اوكرانيا الان تكمن في استدعاء
اكبر عدد من المجندين للتعبئه مع استمرار
الحرب
مجله الوضع في اوكرانيا سبقه الامر نفسه
في روسيا التي استدعت 300 الف جندي سابق
في سبتمبر 2022
فرار اكثر من 370 الف روسي من البلاد في
الاسبوعين الذين اعقب مرسوم بوتين للتعبئه
[موسيقى]
الى جورجيا الان حيث قرر الحزب الحاكم سحب
مشروع قانون يهدد عمل وسائل الاعلام
والمنظمات غير الحكوميه بعد ان اثار
احتجاجات متواصله اعتراضا عليها حيث شبهه
معارضوه بقانون روسي اقر لاسكات المعارضين
في المقابل اكدت رئيسه جورجيا سالومي
زورابي انها ستستخدم حق النقض ضد مشروع
القانون
جورجيا مشاهدينا لطالما لعبت عمليه
التوازن بين مشاعر مواطنيها المؤيده
لاوروبا والاهداف الجيو السياسيه لجارتها
القويه روسيا وهو ما اكده تقرير لشبكه
الاخباريه والتي كشفت ايضا امكانيه تحول
جورجيا الى اوكرانيا القادمه حيث لاحظ
المحللون وجود اوجه تشابه بين الوضع في
جورجيا واوكرانيا وكلاهما من الجمهوريات
السوفيتيه السابقه التي وجدت نفسها محاصره
بين الشرق والغرب حسب سيلان فالحرب في
جورجيا عام 2008 استمرت لايام فقط لكن
يبدو ان بوتين لديه نفس الطموحات
الانتقاميه التي دفعته لغزو اوكرانيا بحسب
السياده وفي جورجيا مشاهدينا يثير قانون
العملاء الاجانب الذي طرحته الحكومه والذي
يستهدف وسائل الاعلام ومنظمات غير
الحكوميه جدلا واسعا في البلاد حيث ادى
الى احتجاجات كبيره في اوساط المعارضه
التي ترفضه لان روسيا هي من تسيطر عليه
بالوقوف وراءه بطريقه غير مباشره
جورجيا ساحه صراع جديده بين روسيا والغرب
والسبب قانون العملاء الاجانب الذي اثار
احتجاجات كبيره في هذا البلد المنقسم بين
روسيا والغرب القانون المثير للجدل الذي
يرى المتظاهرون بانهم امتداد للسياسه
روسيا التي لطالما حاولت فرض سيطرتها
بطريقه غير مباشره على البلاد مثلما تفعله
الان مع اوكرانيا ينص على ان المنظمات غير
الحكوميه ووسائل الاعلام التي تتلقى اكثر
من 20% من تمويلها من الخارج ملزمه
بالتسجيل على انهم عملاء اجانب تحت طائله
الغرامه كما خلف القانون ازمه سياسيه تنذر
بانقسام في السلطه وصراع داخلي في حزب
الحلم الجورجي وايضا تململا واستياء
كبيرين في اوساط المتظاهرين الغاضبين اصلا
من دعم موسكو الانفصاليين جورجيين بعض
النواب في بالحاكم ممن يدعمون موسكو وفقوا
على هذا القانون الذي يغذي صراع النفوذ
بين روسيا ودول الغرب غير ان رئيسه البلد
وقفت مع المتظاهرين الرافدين لحل المشاكل
على الطريقه الروسيه المعارضه تعتبر ان
القانون يذكر بتشريع روسي يستخدمه الكريم
لقمع الصحافه المستقله ومنظمات حقوق
الانسان وخصومه
نشر الحزب الحاكم بيانا قال فيه انه مستعد
لالغاء مشروع القانون الروسي الذي اثار
الاحتجاجات في شوارع تبليسي لا نصدق هذا
البيان السياسيه لان لدينا تجربه حزينه
للغايه الحلم الجورجي كذب على الشعب عده
مرات
مسؤول التشريع في الاتحاد الروسي اتهم
بروكسيل و واشنطن بتنفيذ انقلاب غير
دستوري في جورجيا بدعمها للمتظاهرين موجها
اصابع الاتهام لبعض وسائل الاعلام
والمنظمات غير الحكوميه بالولاء لامريكا
غير ان رد واشنطن جاء مؤيدا للمتظاهرين
الرافدين لهذا القانون الذي يمكن ان تتبخر
معه كل مساعي الحكومه في توطيد علاقاتها
مع دول الغرب خصوصا الولايات المتحده
يوم جديد في الحرب الاوكرانيه شرق تحتدم
فيه المعارك لبسط السيطره الروسيه على
ضخمه فيما تقاوم كييف بدعم عسكري من الغرب
وفي اخر التطورات الميدانيه افادت الانباء
بوقوع انفجارات قويه في كييف بعد ضربات
مكثفه استهدفت انحاء واسعه من اوكرانيا
الرئيسيه وقال ان موسكو لن تتفادى
المسؤوليه وفي بياننا فدزنسكي بان البنيه
التحتيه الحيويه والمباني السكنيه في عشر
مناطق اوكرانيه تعرضت للقصف في الهجمات
الاخيره
في ملف الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه ايضا كشف
مصدر امني مطلع ان ايران زودت روسيا سرا
بكميات كبيره من الرصاص والصواريخ وقذائف
الهاون في حربها على اوكرانيا وتخطط
لارسال المزيد واضاف المصدر ان السفينتي
شحن يطلق عليهما موسى جليل وابكي ترفعان
العلم الروسي غادرتا ايران بين العاشر
والثاني عشر من يناير متجهتين الى روسيا
عبر بحر قزوين وتحملان ما يقرب من 100
مليون رصاصه وحوالي 300 الف قذيفه وبحسب
المصدر يعتقد ان السفينتين كانتا تحملان
نحو 200 حاويه شحن مليئه بالاسلحه واكد
المصدر نفسه ان الذخيره الخاصه بقاذفات
الصواريخ وقذائف الهاون والمدافع الرشاشه
كانت مدرجه في الشحنات مضيفا ان موسكو
دفعت ثمن الذخيره نقدا والى جانب الدعم
الايراني يتزايد القلق في العواصم الغربيه
بشان احتمال ان تبدا الصين في تزويد روسيا
بالاسلحه وهي خطوه حذره الول ايات المتحده
من انها ستكون لها عواقب وخيمه على بيكين
فيما نفث الصين هذه المزاع
[موسيقى]
يزور وفد دبلوماسي مغربي العراق لمناقشه
ملف اعاده مقاتلي تنظيم داعش من المواطنين
المغاربه حيث تهدف الزياره التي يراسها
وزير العدل المغربي الى عقد اتفاقيه
قضائيه بين البلدين تمهد لاعادتها هؤلاء
بالتزامن اكد مسؤولون سودانيون سعيهم في
سوريا لتسلم عدد من مقاتل التنظيم من اصل
سوداني ايضا
عشرات من هؤلاء المقاتلين السابقين في
صفوف تنظيم داعش هم من المغاربه
والسودانيين ينتظرون فتح ابواب هذا السجن
لكن الى سجن اخر حيث يتوقع ان يكملوا
حالهم هذا في بلادهم بعد اعادتهم اليها
زيارتان متزامنتان لمسؤولين سودانيين
ومغاربه الى سوريا والعراق لبحث ملف اعاده
مواطني الدولتين من سجناء داعش واطفالهم
فالخرطوم تسلمت امراتين وثلاثه اطفال من
المخيمات الخاصه بعوائل مقاتل التنظيم
شمال شرقي سوريا لكن الرباط تحتاج لمزيد
من الوقت الذي يفرضه عليها عدد وانتشار
مواطنيها بين العراق وسوريا
المغرب ارسل وفدا من القضاه والمستشارين
يراسه وزير العدل عبد اللطيف وهبي لعقد
اتفاقيه تمهد الطريق لتسليم مقاتل التنظيم
في السجون العراقيه
وفقا لبيانات حكوميه سابقه فان
1659 مغربيا غادروا البلاد للانضمام الى
حركات ارهابيه وان 250 مقاتلا يقبعون في
السجون السوريه بينهم عشره في السجون
العراقيه كذلك يوجد 400 قاصر في مخيمات
البلدين منهم
153 ولدوا في المغرب والبقيه في المناطق
التي استولى عليها التنظيم
الرباط وبعد نحو 18 عاما اعادت فتح
سفاراتها في بغداد ومعها اعيد فتح قضيه
مقاتل التنظيم الارهابي لتتصدر جدول اعمال
التنسيق الامني والقضائي بين البلدين
المغرب ومنذ عام 2015 سنت قانونا لمواجهه
ظاهره عوده المسلحين بعقوبات تتراوح بين
عشر وخمسه عشره سنه من السجن حاكمت
بمضمونه العشرات وعشرات يستعدون انتظارا
للنطق بالحكم
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه احتجاجات مستمره
في فرنسا ضد تعديل قانون التقاعد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد احتجاجات ملات شوارع
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس اعتراضا على مشروع
قانون لتعديل نظام التقاعد اذ يواصل
العمال في العديد من القطاعات الخدميه
الاحتجاجات ضد خطه الحكومه بشان سن
التقاعد حيث ستتعطل شبكه السكك الحديديه
والحركه الجويه مره اخرى في البلاد لكن
مشاهدينا ورغم الاحتجاجات يبدو ان خطه
حكومه رئيس الفرنسي
لاقرار مشروع قانون لتعديل النظام التقاعد
المثير للجدل في طريقها للاقرار اولى هذه
الخطوات جاءت بتمرير مجلس الشيوخ الفرنسي
ماده رئيسيه في مشروع القانون تنص على رفع
سن التقاعد من 62 الى 64 عاما وذلك رغم
معركه اجرائيه حاده مع اليسار كما صوت 201
من اعضاء الاعضاء اعضاء المجلس لصالح رفع
سن التقاعد مقابل 115 عضوا صوتوا ضده
[موسيقى]
رئيسه الوزراء الفرنسيه اللي زابط بورنو
وصفت مشروع القانوني بالمتوازن والعادل
حيث تعول حكومتها على هذا الاصلاح لضمان
تمويل نظام الضمان الاجتماعي الذي يشكل
احد ركائز النموذج الاجتماعي الفرنسيه
وضمان عدم افلاسه بوقت تظهر الاستطلاعات
ان غالبيه الفرنسيين يعارضون هذا الاصلاح
ويصفونه بالظالم فيما دعه النقابات
العماليه ماكرون الى الانصات الى رفض
الشارع مهدده بمزيد من الاضرابات حتى
العدول عن القانون
العربيه ترصد اوضاع المهاجرين على ضفتي
نهر المانش في مدينه كاليه الفرنسيه
اقتلعت الشرطه الفرنسيه خيام اللاجئين
ووضعت صخورا ثقيله لمنع تواجدهم في
المدينه اما في بريطانيا
فتنتظر المهاجرين الواصلين الى حلمهم
الانجليزيه قوانين قاسيه نتابع
تحت هذا الجسر في مدينه كاليل الفرنسيه
الحدوديه مع بريطانيا ينتظر سوريون لحظه
العبور الى حلمهم الانجليزي
يقاومون قسوه الطقس بنار يشعلونها قرب
خيام مبتله يخشون النوم في الليل اكثر من
عبور بحر المانش كي لا تنطفئ النار
ويقتلهم البرد ما في غيرها
البحر صحراء اي شيء وصل لشيء امان سلام
استقرار الشبان الثلاثه قبلوا الحديث
الينا شريطه ان يظهروا ملثمين حرصا على
عدم اخافه اباء وامهات يظنون ان اولادهم
يعيشون نعيما في اوروبا بالنسبه للبوليس
بوليس يعني كل يوم او كل يومين بيجينا
الصبح يعني تقريبا شي الساعه سبعه الصبح
ولا بخليه شيم وباخذ كل شي بتجيب لنا اياه
الامم وبسحب حاله وبطلع واحيانا هذا الوضع
دفع جمعيات فرنسيه وبريطانيه الى التحرك
والاحتجاج على تصرفات الشرطه التي تضيق
الخناقه على عملهم ايضا
بدات الشرطه وبلديه بوضع اسلاك وصخور لمنع
المهاجرين من نصب خيامهم
في هذه النقطه الحدوديه في مدينه كاليش
ماليه فرنسا كان المهاجرون ينتظرون حلم
العبور الى بريطانيا داخل خيام جاءت
الشرطه وقتلعتها ووضعت هذه الصخور الثقيله
مكانها لكي تمنعهم من العوده الى هنا لكن
هؤلاء المسؤولين في جمعيات فرنسيه
وبريطانيه جاءوا لازاحه الصخور واعطاء امل
جديد للمهاجرين بامكانيه العبور الى
بريطانيا وان كان عبر قوارب متهالكه في
البحر على الجانب الاخر من الحدود تقف
الزميله عروف عبد الحق لترصد المشهد
اقل ما يمكن وصفها اما برحله موت او رحله
الى المجهول الناجون منها تتلقفهم اجراءات
بريطانيا الجدليه
على طول مسار الساحل الانجليزي هذا متحدين
امواجا عاتيه احيانا يصل معظم اللاجئين
الى هذه النقطه عبر قوارب الموت في رحله
تستغرق ساعه واربعين دقيقه يضحون بكل شيء
على امل الوصول الى بلاد تعرف بنظام
مساعدات لكن قوانين الهجره المتغيره شرعان
ما تبدد احلامهم فروض الذي طلب منا عدم
ذكر اسمه الحقيقي يجهل مصيره الى الان
يفضل الانتحار على ان يتم ترحيله الى
رواندا
اذا اجبرت على الذهاب الى رواندا فقد اقدم
على الانتحار لا اريد الذهاب الى هناك لا
استطيع التفسير لكن لا اريد الذهاب الى
رواندا المشكله بحسب حقوقيين يعملون على
مقلوبه من اللاجئين هنا ان مشروع القرار
يضع اللاجئين بشكل تلقائي خارجا نظام
اللجوء
من اكثر الاشياء المحبطه ان ياتي يا اصحاب
المهارات الى هذا البلد وتكون بوجههم
عقبات سواء اذا كانوا طالبي لجوء او طالبي
اعاده توطين لذا اعتقد ان اللاجئين هم
الحل لا يحق للواصلين هنا طلبوا حق اللجوء
او الخروج من دوامات الاحتجاج المعقده ما
يعني وضعهم في طي النسيان في مراكز
احتجازا حتى حل المشاكل القانونيه
والاخلاقيه التي تخلقها قوانين اللجوء
البريطانيه من مدينه
معنا من باريس العربيه حسين قنيبر الان
حسين اهلا بك معنا موضوع المهاجرين بين
فرنسا وبريطانيا على ضفتين المانش سيكون
احد المواضيع الرئيسيه في نقاشات رئيس
الوزراء البريطانيه الذي يصل غدا الى
باريس في زياره رسميه
ما الذي
سيتوقع ان تخرج به هذه الزياره فيما يتعلق
بملف المهاجرين غير الشرعيين
نعم في الواقع صهيب هذه زياره المهمه
لرئيس الوزراء البريطاني هي الاولى منذ
خمس سنوات لرئيس وزراء بريطاني الى باريس
وهي تسبق باسبوعين زياره سيقوم بها ملك
بريطانيا الثالث الى باريس هذه الزياره
طبعا سيرافق ريشيسوناك فيها سبعه وزراء
يلتقون بنظراتهم الفرنسيين هم وزراء
الخارجيه والداخليه والدفاع والاقتصاد
والطاقه والنقل والبيئه ستكون هناك عده
موضوعات تناقش من بينها استمرار الدعم
العسكري الذي تقوم به فرنسا وبريطانيا
لاوكرانيا وايضا التعاون الدفاعي وكذلك
التعاون الاقتصادي وفي مجال الاستثمارات
ولكن خصوصا وهنا عود الى سؤالك في مجال
مكافحه الهجره غير الشرعيه صدر بيان عن
الاليزا الليله يشير الى ان البلدين
سيناقشان خصوصا التعاون الامني وايضا
التعاون في مكافحه الارهاب
المخدرات والتطرف والهجره غير الشرعيه في
هذا المجال سيناقش الجانبان سبل تنفيذ
معاهده الساند هيرست التي وقعت بين
البلدين عام 2018
وتنفيذ بنود الاتفاق الذي توصل اليه في
نوفمبر من العام الماضي والذي قضى ان
تدفعه بريطانيا لفرنسا مبلغ 72 مليون يورو
مقابل ان ترفع فرنسا عدد عناصر الامن عند
الحدود البحريه بين البلدين من 800 الى
900 عنصر امن لمكافحه القوارب غير الشرعيه
التي تنقل المهاجرين الى بريطانيا هذا عن
زياره ريجيسونا الى باريس غدا يصلك عن
الشان الداخلي الفرنسي جدل كبير حول قانون
التقاعد ما يزال مستمرا وكذلك حركه اضراب
واسعه ولكن مع ذلك يبدو ان القانون في
طريقه الى الاقرار التفاصيل الحسين
تماما فجر اليوم يعني الليل الاربعاء
الخميس تبنى مجلس الشيوخ
باكثريه البند السابع المثير للجدل من
مشروع قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد والمتعلق
تحديدا برفع سن التقاعد من 62 عاما الى 64
عاما لكن هذا لم يوقف التحرك الشعبي
والنقابي والحزب الحزبي اليساري تحديدا
بعد تظاهرات واضراب يوم الثلاثاء الماضي
التظاهرات التي جمعت ثلاثه ملايين ونصف
المليون فرنسي نزلوا الى الشوارع الثلاثاء
استمرت التحركات يوم امس واليوم اليوم كان
يوم تحرك المنظمات الشبابيه التابعه
للنقبات العماليه الرئيسيه ولاحزاب اليسار
وشملت هذه التحركات عده قطاعات من بينها
خصوصا قطاعات الصحه والنقل والتعليم
والطاقه وايضا قطاع الصناعات الكيماويه
وقطاع عمال جمع النفايات في باريس
3700 طن من الن فايات لم ترفع مما ادى الى
انبعاث رائحه كريهه من بعض الاحياء هذه
الليله صهيب
شكرا جزيلا لك حسين قنيبر مباشره من باريس
نذهب للحديث الان عن مجال التكنولوجيا
يبدو ان يبدو ان تطبيق تيك توك لم يعد
يحمل اهدافه الاساسيه التي صمم من اجلها
فمدير مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه
الامريكيه كريستوفر كشف للجنه الاستخبارات
بمجلس الشيوخ ان الحكومه الصينيه يمكن ان
تستخدم تيك توك للتحكم في البيانات الخاصه
بملايين الاشخاص وتسخير تطبيق الفيديو
القصير للتوجيه الراي العام والتحكم فيه
في حاله غزو الصين
من جهته قال الرئيس التنفيذيه لمنصه تيك
توك شوزي ان الحكومه الصينيه لم تطلب
بيانات المستخدمين في الولايات المتحده
وان الشركه لن توفرها اذا طلبت الحكومه
ذلك
[موسيقى]
في عالم التكنولوجيا اصبح الذكاء
الاصطناعي موضوع الساعه على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي حيث احتل حيزا واسعا من
اهتمامات الناس والتطلعاتهم فزاد البحث
عنه خصوصا لدى الافراد المهتمين
بالتكنولوجيا لكنه في الوقت عينه يثير
قلقا واسع النطاق لدى الاشخاص وفقا
الاستطلاعات راي نقلتها عن مركز بيور
للابحاث وجامعه
الى خبر اخر زارت اليوم السيده الاولى
الاوكرانيه اولينا زيلينسكا زوجه رئيس
الاوكرانيه
العربيه في دبي اجرت السيده الاولى جوله
في جميع الاقسام اضافه الى مقابله سيتم
بثها لاحقا علما بان السيد الاوكرانيه
الاولى موجوده في دوله الامارات حتى
العاشر من مارس الحالي للمشاركه في النسخه
الثانيه من قمه التي تستضيفها ابو ظبي
بهذا تنتهي اخبار الساعه تذكير بابرز
العناوين
حزمه عقوباتنا الامريكيه جديده موجهه ضد
ايران وتطال شركات صينيه تساعد طهران في
صنع المسيرات
استراليا تقرر شراء غواصات امريكيه نوويه
والصين تحدرها وتدعو للتخلي عن عقليه
الحرب البارده
واشنطن في تدريب طيارنا اوكرانيين على
طائرات الاف سته عشر وتدرس تركيب اسلحه
امريكيه على المقاتلات الاوكرانيه
خطوات مغربيه وسودانيه نحو تسلم عدد من
عائلات مقاتلي داعش المحتجزين في سجون
العراق وسوريا
شكرا لكم على كرم مشاهده اخبار الساعه
لهذه الليله المزيد على العربيه على
صفحتنا على مواقع التواصل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]